mais l' île en mer marie galante voilà
qui nous ramène ou qui nous mène à la
poésie et à la chanson et nous recevoir
ce soir carla bruni bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous sortez votre deuxième album il y a
quelques semaines nos premiers 6 alors
ses onze titres qui sont autant
d'adaptations de poèmes classiques en
anglais on en parlera dans un instant le
temps d'écouter un extrait de cet album
assez surprenant vous y interpréter la
un texte de christiana rossetti
promesse de taken from the bridge et
nassim abassi glace magnifique affaire
connexe
on retrouve les mêmes atmosphère soyeuse
que dans quelqu'un m'a dit on retrouve
du son on retrouve votre arrangeur la
patte de louis bertignac on en entend
votre voix mais on n'a pas vos mots on a
le mot des autres alors pourquoi avoir
choisi les mots des autres
c'est vrai en instantané monnaie en fait
j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour toute
cette poésie anglo saxon qui est
anglaise américaine irlandaise un coup
de foudre est un peu inexplicable et
peut-être absurde c'est vrai qu'à des
magnifiques poèmes en français en
italien un signe qui ont été déjà
merveilleusement chanter et j'ai eu
envie de chanter ses poèmes sens mais
votre source avoué le qatari c'est pour
ça que vous avez pas le chercheur
italien j'ai tout de même écrit toute la
musique dont je sais pas si elle était
tout à fait tout à fait pareil mais en
ce qui concerne les paroles vous savez
une chanson est faite de parole et de
musique et les deux choses comptent de
la même manière c'est vrai que en france
on donne beaucoup d'importance aux
paroles c'est un pays très riche
horaires et c'est normal parce que le
français est une langue magnifique à
écrire lire et et aussi à chanter bien
sûr alors en même temps ce sont des
textes fin 19e début 20e vous dégagez
plutôt l'image d'une femme moderne et là
ce sont des textes anciens
là pas de contradiction je les trouve
pas tellement siens peut-être un petit
peu anciens dans l'ordre dans la date à
laquelle ils correspondent
mais pas tellement anciens dans les
thèmes qui est qui qui proposent dans
les questions qui se posent et dans la
leur musique aussi pasquet musique très
forte dans la poésie romantique du 19e
siècle de
du xxème siècle c'est un petit peu non
je les trouve moches
je dirais pas moderne dans le sens
informatique dit mot mais moderne dans
le sens des sentiments qui sont toujours
un peu intemporel alors je le disais
tout à l'heure vous persistez vous
signez puisque vous publiez également un
recueil de poésie 50 texte que vous avez
choisi de la même époque
alors ils sont à la fois en anglais est
traduit en français et moi je pense que
la poésie ça se dit aussi ce que vous
pourriez avoir la gentillesse de nous
lire le petit extrait que j'ai mis de
côté je sais pas si je suis une très
très bonne les deux c'est un c'est un
petit extrait d'un poème de wisteria
aude qui s'appelle finale blues sympa
mais ses célèbres notamment en
angleterre alors j'ai voulu y voir une
menace mais tout comme song a tort
c'était mon or mon sud monde est et
ouest
mon travail mon repos montmédy minuit ma
parole mme montchamp
je pensais que l'amour durait toujours
j'avais tort merci beaucoup en tout cas
c'est avec ses jolis mots quand on
termine notre entretien merci d'avoir
gravitation